Godzilla king of the monsters is set to
follow up a film that reimagined cinemas
favorite fire-breathing behemoth and
left everyone with plenty of questions
like how does the movie connect to its
predecessors and is Godzilla really the
king or is he just some scaly ass poser
don't worry we've got the answers you're
looking for a host of stars are joining
the gut Zilla family for king of the
monsters the star-studded cast includes
the conjuring franchise veteran Vera
Farmiga as paleo biologist dr. Emma
Russel stranger things darling Millie
Bobby Brown is Madison Russell and
Friday Night Lights alum Kyle Chandler
as animal behavior expert dr. Marc
Russell Emma's ex-husband though there
are more than a handful of new
characters to meet in Godzilla king of
the monsters the film doesn't go without
a few returning favorites the actors
returning for king of the monsters
include Ken Watanabe and Sally Hawkins
Watanabe slips back into the crisp white
lab coat of his Godzilla character dr.
akido Serizawa a scientist at the
cryptozoological organization monarch
Hopkins will be back as SETI Sawa's
right-hand woman dr. Vivian Graham
another actor coming back for king of
the monsters godzilla himself
professional stuntman TJ storm reprises
the monstrous role in a motion capture
performance
the vast majority of sequels use the
ending of the direct precursors as a
springboard to launch into new narrative
territory Godzilla king of the monsters
is no exception
set in 2019 five years after 2014's
Godzilla king of the monsters centers
around the members of monarch as they go
head to head with a battery of god-sized
monsters and by that we mean godzilla
and his three foes Rodin Ghidorah and
Mothra mankind once believed the ancient
super species collectively known as
Titans were the stuff of fiction the
Titans are all too real and threaten
humanity's existence when they rise to
fight for dominance Godzilla king of the
monsters also sees dr. emma russell and
her daughter Madison get kidnapped by a
mysterious organization that wants to
use Emma's intellect and inventiveness
as well as Madison's strange connection
with Mothra for nefarious purposes Emma
feels humans and Titans can coexist
peacefully but after experiencing a
great loss her ex-husband mark doesn't
agree despite holding a negative view of
the monsters mark teams of monarchs dr.
akido Serizawa and dr. Vivian Graham to
rescue Emma and Madison Godzilla king of
the monsters will bring Mothra Road in
and give Dhara back to the big screen
and we've got the skinny on who the
three creatures are and how they'll be
depicted a colossal moth like being
Mothra will be both beautiful and deadly
in king of the monsters director Michael
Dougherty aimed to give her a realistic
appearance including long legs that help
her fight against and defend herself
from her adversaries Rodin on the other
hand is a pterodactyl like monster
described by Doherty as a massive a bomb
and a bit of a rogue with incredible
physical power Doherty elaborated you
never quite know where his loyalties lie
Godzilla's more of a lumbering plotting
presence it takes him a couple of days
to destroy a city like Tokyo Rodin can
level it without even thinking as for
Ghidorah the three-headed dragon beast
is Godzilla's ultimate nemesis that each
of his heads has its own different
personality one alpha and two lackeys
mix Ghaderi even more formidable than
Godzilla's other challengers
get these on our side
the title of Godzilla king of the
monsters tells audiences all they need
to know about the monsters ranking in
the Titan hierarchy he's the Big Kahuna
the Grand Poobah the top banana but what
about where Godzilla stands on the hero
villain binary is Bradley Whitford dr.
stanton states in one of the film's
trailers godzilla is on our side and can
help save mankind from being eradicated
as soon as monarch sets him free though
godzilla isn't out to harm humans not
everyone is totally willing to consider
him the good guy O'Shea Jackson jr.
whose character Barnes leads monarchs
military crew the G team told Fandango
that Godzilla is a heroic protector
speaking as a Godzilla fan I always
hated those humans who acted like
Godzilla didn't just save their ass what
happened in San Francisco and 2014 in
Godzilla from what I can see
he holds down the Pacific so California
seems safe so I'm down with that
on the converse Kyle Chandler who's dr.
mark Russell has a troubled history with
the Titans isn't a fan of any of the
Titans
Godzilla included explaining they're
mean ugly dangerous and they've caused
havoc with marks family looks like some
will be esident to bow down to the king
that could be their undoing or gift cuts
all have a chance to prove them wrong
Godzilla king of the monsters maybe as
fresh as it can be in terms of its time
setting taking place in 2019 the same
year of its release but it also
incorporates elements of the past
talking with Fandango director Michael
Dougherty detailed that the concept of
the king of the monsters is rooted in
the mythology that the world belongs to
the Titans since they were on earth long
before humans came along in his words
humans are the invasive species and
Titans are quote the old gods the first
gods he also shared that king of the
monsters gives the creatures according
to him a more mythological almost
biblical backdrop when exploring their
history Doherty explained these
creatures were once worshipped by some
ancient civilization I really love that
about the old movies that Mothra was
this deity it really opened up the
mythology in simple terms king of the
monsters sees ancient mythology clash
with the modern day bringing humans and
godlike beasts together at the same
point in time it's a union partially
motivated by a childhood wish of
Dougherty who said as a kid it always
bummed me out that dinosaurs never
actually crossed paths with hee
so I'm saying that the five-year break
between Godzilla and king of the
monsters leaves a lot of time
unaccounted for though we can't say for
certain whether king of the monsters
will explain the in world events that
went down between 2014 and 2019 for how
the film will address the gap we assure
you that another piece of Godzilla
content definitely will as of 10 days
ahead of king of the monsters may 31st
debut fans can dig into Godzilla
aftershock the legendary comics
published tie-in prequel graphic novel
takes place in the time after Godzilla
and before king of the monsters and sets
the stage for the sequel written by
Arvid Nelson with artwork by drew Edward
Johnson Godzilla aftershock continues
the plot laid out in Godzilla seeing an
all-new monster Muto Prime ascends from
deep within the planet and Godzilla
battle and unstoppable primal instinct
that challenges his inner strength
the graphic novel also introduces
several characters from king of the
monsters as dr. Emma Russel and the
members of Monarch try to put an end to
the creature and attempt to piece
together the truth behind a past tragedy
of apocalyptic proportions that is
resurfacing again as Godzilla fights in
a rivalry that spans as many years as
the earth has been a planet Emma
unravels secrets beyond anyone's wildest
imagination king of the monsters is
about more than a bunch of behemoths
trading blows in fact it carries a
message about environmentalism the role
humans play in the destruction of planet
Earth and the importance of science in
our modern society director Michael
Dougherty told Fandango in a time when
in our current climate for science is
being constantly questioned and targeted
the idea of creating a film where
scientists are heroes thought was really
important so you'd want to make Godzilla
our pet
No we with these star Vera Farmiga even
described the movie as being more about
environmentalism than your average
monster filled flick which is what drew
her to the project nowadays you'd be
hard pressed to find a modern film that
doesn't deliver fanservice in the form
of Easter eggs they become the norm in
contemporary cinema with audiences
practically squirming in their seats at
the thought of finding every last hidden
secret tucked inside a new release it
should come as a little surprise that
Godzilla king of the monsters will
continue this trend but what you should
know about the sneaky references is that
some will set up the future of the
Godzilla franchise actor O'Shea Jackson
jr. told Fandango during a set visit in
2017 that he was quote nerding out
really hard over the Easter eggs and
king of the monsters and said that fans
will have a blast trying to uncover them
all director Michael Doherty piggybacked
off Jackson Junior's remarks when he
told Entertainment Weekly that the film
will also tease the introduction of
another famous movie creature post king
of the monsters King Kong Doherty share
it's not like we're bending over
backwards to introduce Kong but there's
definitely some bread crumbs grab your
binoculars and a basket before heading
out to see king of the monsters as the
movie-going experience sounds like it
will double as a massive Easter egg hunt
Godzilla king of the monsters is no
average sequel it expands the revived
world that Godzilla set up and calls
back to the old-school monster movies
produced by Toho the Japanese company
responsible for 32 Godzilla films it
also sets up a new cinematic universe
packed with monsters and centered on
monarchs undertakings that will stretch
across multiple releases king of the
monsters not only serves as the sequel
to Godzilla but also as the next entry
in warner brothers initial trio of
monster verse movies which see godzilla
exist among a wide variety of other
giant super monsters new and old
additionally director Michael Dougherty
once mentioned that king of the monsters
hinges on something of a crossover event
as the film unites the creatures
featured in Toho's classics Doherty told
the folks at Fandango outside of the
Universal classic monster movies Toho is
one of the first companies to pioneer
the idea of a shared universe they were
doing it long before Marvel was Mothra
was a completely separate film from
Godzilla when it started same thing with
Rodin so it kind of feels like things
are coming full circle
king of the monsters before Godzilla
king of the monsters even released its
first trailer the bigwigs at Warner
Brothers and Legendary Pictures
announced plans for a sequel you know
that third entry into the studio's
Godzilla trilogy the last piece of the
first wave of monster verse movies and
the film that the king of the monsters
will tease with its references to King
Khan that one after Lee entitled
Godzilla vs. Kong the king of the
monsters sequel has death notes Adam
Wingard on board as director with many
cast members back in the fold the plot
of Godzilla versus Kong will center
around a brutal brawl between Godzilla
and the gorilla like monster monkey the
film which stars Alexander Skarsgard as
the leader of a military unit as well as
Rebecca Hall Jessica Henrik Bryant Irie
Henry and more also focuses on
humanity's fight for its future monarchs
mission to discover the truth about the
Titans and a conspiracy that threatens
to end life on Earth continues make no
mistake though there will be a clear
winner of the titular battle when it all
goes down on March 13 2020 as Wingard
once confirmed I do want people to walk
away from this film feeling like okay
there is a winner wonderful King check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]